well many who delayed travel plans
during the pandemic are finally booking
that trip while the airline industry is
concerned that spiking gas prices will
limit consumer spending power and hurt
demand for airfare experts say it seems
people are willing to spend more to do
it
scott's cheap flights recently surveyed
a portion of its three million members
asking what travel would look like for
them this year while the pandemic and
restrictions were the reasons given why
not to travel for the past two years now
the number one reason that folks cited
was money people said if i don't travel
this year it won't be because i was
afraid of hope it wouldn't be because of
restrictions it's because i just can't
afford it the cost of domestic flights
is increasing by about 36 percent due to
high demand after two years of covid and
soaring fuel prices previously consumers
could expect a three-month delay between
rising fuel prices and ticket fares but
now airlines are changing prices at a
much quicker pace however despite this
nerd wallet survey data out this week
found 70 percent of people are planning
leisure travel this year the top
destinations that folks want to get to
this summer overwhelming majority said
hey cities i want to get back to rome
again i want to get back to paris i want
to take london on my bucket list so we
expect there to be a big travel boom for
folks heading into europe into those big
cities once again
willis orlando says there are round
trips from vegas to madrid spain for
about 475 bucks and vegas to costa rica
for just under 300 but again books that
travel now it's only going to increase